as we told you earlier President Trump
has just signed an executive order
imposing stiff penalties for assaults on
us monuments the director of the FBI
says federal law enforcement will not
tolerate rioting and destruction of
those monuments Christopher Rea telling
Fox News hundreds of individuals are
being investigated for what he calls
violent extremist agendas correspondent
David spot has details as monuments fall
across the country FBI agents are
watching it in real-time from this room
the FBI recognizes the rights of our
American citizens to exercise their
First Amendment rights however when it
crosses into a Leela illegal activity
it's something that we have to address
Fox News was granted exclusive access to
the FBI's strategic information and
operation center where officials are
watching trends in vandalism responding
to those trends and synthesizing and he
collected intelligence to find the next
hotspots across the country we fully
expected going into the last couple
weeks that individuals to include
extremists would take advantage of
Americans exercising their right to
peacefully protest in sort of what I
would call hijack that for their own
personal opportunistic acts of
committing criminal activity or violence
from Portland Oregon to Boston
Massachusetts unrest continues to
blanket dozens of cities some cases city
officials removed statues but other
times crowds took control pulling down
statues like this one of Confederate
General Albert Pike before setting it on
fire the violence and destruction of
property that we've been seeing in
certain parts of the country is illegal
and it needs to stop now FBI director
Christopher ray tells FOX News his job
is to strike the right balance equal
justice is essential but violence and
destruction of property is not the way
to ensure it agents in this room are
also watching social media chatter and
other communications to uncover any
potential terrorism network hoping to
cash in on the unrest what I would ask
for those that watch this right is we
need your help we need information
that you see we need see something say
something as time ticks closer to the
November election FBI officials expect
to see more of this criminal activity
but when it happens they'll be ready
Brett David thank you